hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca on monster underworld
again and today we're gonna be talking
about burial and in specific a little
gaiden how to beat him solo and my
opinion I think that bury earth is the
my like I said in my opinion I think
he's like one of the first toughest
fights in ice born if not the first
toughest fight you know the coral
bouquet bouquet he was a bit tough but
not too crazy nice shape aluminum also
it wasn't that crazy either but I still
I think Barry authors like the first
fight that really kind of tells you hey
welcome to master rank [ __ ] gets tough
here yeah with that we're gonna be going
over the move set some of the stuff
around him in the area his physiology
report general tidbits and stuff like
that so I was like the V if you do enjoy
subscribers renew a couple of monster
guides and the solo stuff for Monster
Hunter roles especially during ice burn
I'm gonna be doing a lot of this stuff
as I keep progressing through the game
and with that guys let's get started
with today's video the allergy report he
is most weak to fire with all ailments
being two-star and thunder also being a
two-star he's also completely resistant
to ice and water so there's really no
point in using Mo's you might as well
just stick with fire for some
recommendations I recommend an ice proof
rock steady or temporal mantle I highly
I do highly recommend the ice proof
Menzel we'll get into that a little bit
later but if you don't want to bring
that of course you bring the other two
that I mentioned as well also bring some
Nell berries or have some type of armor
that has over 20 ice resistance if you
have over 20 resistance and an element
you can negate the blight and in this
case it's going to be ice blade at this
point in the early game of ice born
either you get some high rank ice
production gear or the only master rank
options to really have are the Guardian
set you get with ice born or the and
it's got decent stats don't get me wrong
but the defense really isn't that great
I mean I've been too shot with that
thing so it's probably not the best way
to go the only monster I really believe
at this point is bait Otis the fish
[ __ ] thing that you fight in the very
beginning if you're watching this a
little bit later and hopes to farm him
there's probably a way better ice
protection gear out there from maybe Val
Connor or anybody in the future of
course but at this point the story mode
bait Otis is probably your best bet in
terms of ice resistance so if you're
really keen on getting that I would farm
him for a little bit he's really not
that hard of a monster anyway so
shouldn't take you too long now with
that out of the way let's get to his
moveset
so Barry out there's quick
deadly but that doesn't mean you need
fast weapons I started using the DU
Bois's in the beginning realizing the
same type of mentality but then coming
to figure out that honestly hammers can
do just as good of a job in fact that's
actually how I beat him after a couple
tries with some other testing of weapons
the hammer seemed to be the one that
finally killed him in this area on
screen I've watched for the ice and the
edges by the way this goes off into like
that ledge that goes often like
nothingness for some [ __ ]
those can fall and seriously hurt you if
you aren't careful bury off to come like
trigger those to fall also don't even
bother trying to get him to fall in
there because it's going to do no damage
he just fly over it so it really doesn't
matter very office a couple moves in the
air one to close the gap and the other
to do ice boy one is a dive bomb you can
come you can go around him and not have
to Superman jump as I called it or if
you're caught too early definitely go
for the jump to utilize those iframes
if you happen to be on the ground while
he does this like I said I would
recommend staying just on the ground as
usual is if you get up too early my
hichy twice he would get up too late you
might get hit by another move if you
guessed too wrong so obviously you don't
want to go too early you know want to go
too late you want to find that perfect
gap between the two so you are getting
double hook because obviously that can
lead to a concussion you're gonna get
knocked out gonna have to shake yourself
back and bury off can even get a third
hit in and that's not good stuff
especially how much damage he does it
very early in this game
Beth usually tries to fly away to
confuse and recover don't let him get
out of your sight too many times he's
pounced right away from me and then
right after he does this tail swipe and
then carts me way too many damn times
has he done that the tail swipe does
also cause I split so definitely keep
that in mind Bharath also loves to use
the walls as a platform to jump
sometimes he goes for you sometimes he
goes for your pelic oh just check to
make sure and then dodge accordingly you
don't want to be dodging when he's not
going for you because that's wasted time
barry off doesn't simply swing his arms
and but he carries his momentum with him
almost every one-handed attack he does
he swings his arm right around you to
get right behind you and then right back
to hit you again so if we dodge or
happen to be hit watch out for the
second hit because you might get hit
twice or you might get it from the
second hit and you don't want to be
doing that like I said he's very tough
at the very beginning of the game that
was a lot of damage you know what we can
hit that much
I really noticed two main ways of
attacking him are really far and really
close I like to rush underneath his
belly personally surprise him with a
nice upswing from the hammer but
everybody plays it differently going
back to that airborne move I talked
about he can also do it on the ground he
shouts a giant gust of ice and when kind
of like ku shallows tornadoes but they
cause ice play and also unlike KU
shallows they go away almost instantly
so there's no worries about that taking
up space in the area so thank [ __ ] for
that as you can see what the next move
we have a shoulder charge and this is
usually followed with a hop I really
don't understand this it's like some hop
skip jump type [ __ ] but every time
he hops he'd get ready to dodge because
he will do a shoulder charge you can
also tell which side he hits cuz if he
goes right to gain that power then he
hits left vice-versa if he goes a little
bit to the left he'll bash right [ __ ]
like that but I'll see the reaction is a
bit too quick so you might not even
notice it but definitely watch out for
the hop because that's the most apparent
one for some more tips whatever bury out
smacks me to get too close I usually try
to close the gap on him or run for a
quick second if I need to heal I'll back
off as well but if I'm ready to square
up I confronts him right away with a
hammer to the face maybe some dual blade
action stuff like that you don't want to
be second-guessing yourself and
hesitating and being stuck in the middle
because then he's gonna clip you so just
try to commit as much as possible but
speaking of that later the more you
fight him the more tired of course he's
going to get he'll start to slip on his
spin attacks and if you're quick enough
depending on the weapon you have of
course if your ranged this might be
actually a lot more effective you can
get some hits in but obviously not a
full combo since his recovery is quick
so if you're gonna if you have an idea
and you want to get a full combo I would
try to stay away from that as you might
get clipped while he's trying to get up
so maybe a couple hits you know what
here and there would be pretty fun I
really don't know the numbers of the
sector's you fight in so I'll just show
the places on the screen to give you a
visual here you fight around in this
area I believe it's one of the I think
it's the first area you fight him in and
drop Barry off by KO or mounting stuff
like that
these new babo creatures will start
throwing sleep Spears at him which is
nice but sometimes they end up waking
him because they throw too many but
regardless if they don't do it it can
really help obviously sleep damage is
super powerful especially depending on
the weapon you have
like a hammer or great sword can be easy
damage right away for no cost in this
room there are some areas to gain height
and possibly mount I didn't really like
this area too much it was very open
which was pretty nice but there wasn't
much to help me a little bit later on
you'll be getting into this other
smaller area and there'll be a couple
icicles in this room which are super
useful against them there's also some
flash pods and a little air a little
ledge that you can mount on there's also
these guys I think they're called slugs
or a glugs or something like that this
little like squirrel looking dudes that
are just kind of chillin in that area if
the monster is actually Kayode whatever
way you happen to do it and they're
knocked out it will actually help you by
getting like ten damage per second it's
really not much but when there's like
three or four of them ganging up on the
one it's pretty interested it's actually
kind of funny to watch it but it is
extra damage so they do help you a
little bit so try to do that when
they're nearby and then eventually
you're gonna be getting to this icicle
area with a lot of like types of the
stalactites and just these icicles just
everywhere for some reason I can't
really explain this area but you'll see
on the screen there is a pool of ice so
definitely don't want to step in that
you're gonna be getting ice boy I don't
actually know if the ice resistance has
anything to help with this but that
would that would need some further
testing but yeah eventually he's gonna
start breaking [ __ ] there's going to be
a small stream that actually when you
walk through it will give that ice
blight as well it doesn't happen
instantly you can tell how close you are
to getting it by how much ice is on your
character if ice completely surrounds
her character you're very close to
getting ice plate but if it's only on
your legs you got a couple seconds but I
wouldn't stand in that stuff too long
there can be possible turf wars but even
when he was near Viper Toby bond burrow
and full ger Anjanette he didn't do a
single turf war so I'm not actually sure
maybe it's just unlucky or berry out
those and new turf wars still don't
really understand that part I mean I
don't even touch any of them and still
no turf wars so very sad about that
wanting to see some nice little action
there and that's about it
you can kill her capture him it's
completely your choice I'm a big fan of
capturing especially with this new dlc
of monsters just want to get this stuff
over with and not have to do with that
extra 30% of the fight but i do have one
question though not really entirely sure
how i didn't rank this [ __ ] guy i was
not my second attempt end up failing
because I thought I ended up shrinking
him for sure I thought everything was in
place but I guess I did
if you guys know how what happened let
me know in the comments below cuz I mean
the skull was there he was limping
you're sleeping everything was set up
and he didn't rank he didn't get
captured still kind of confused about
that yeah like I said that's gonna be
the end of the bait a hopefully you guys
did enjoy hopefully this helps you guys
beat Barry off he's a very tough monster
as I said probably the first toughest
fight and ice born so far I like I said
the other guys pukka pukka then paluma
at me on the subspecies they were hard
they were tough but they weren't as
tough as Barry off of my opinion he's
super quick super fast and he's kind of
a [ __ ] so that's why I wanted to make
the scout for you guys because obviously
I want everyone to get all that juicy
info and if I happen to miss something
or if I happen to get something wrong
let me know in the comments below and
I'll be sure to update in a pin comment
somewhere down in the and the comments
down below with all the info that
everyone displays to me so that you can
also get some extra tidbits from the
community of people that come to this
video which would be greatly appreciated
but that guys like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe or you know I cover the solo
guides of Monster Hunter World just
trying to make sure everyone can get all
the best info so that they don't have a
tough time trying to go through the game
and try to have a good experience and
experience the story of monster hunter
world especially with the new ice borne
DLC we all kind of want to figure out
the [ __ ] going on so I'm here to help
that guy I hope your day hopefully just
a bit easier with these guys and if
you're having trouble with some monsters
because I understand some of these guys
can be very pain in the ass and I
understand that I also want to apologize
if the audio was pretty shitty if I was
stuttering or anything like that I
haven't slept if this thing came out
like seven hours ago and I'm it's like
6:00 in the morning right now I haven't
slept so I do apologize for that when
you guys take care have a greatest today
hopefully you're enjoying ice-born let
me know in the comments below
I think everyone peace out
[Music]